por qué
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia y aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cura de la
humanidad
la población de elefantes en kenia se ha
duplicado durante los últimos 30 años
mientras que en el resto del continente
cada vez se cuentan menos individuos
guardabosques se encargan de vigilar que
no haya conflictos entre estos gigantes
y las poblaciones rurales
los niños son los más afectados por la
pandemia de kobe 19 en el continente
africano desde escolarización falta de
atención en salud y un declive en la
calidad de la alimentación ponen en
peligro a los menores tanto en el norte
como en el sur del continente tenemos
reporte
y como emprendo museo afrocolombiano
esos tiempos de pandemia ante la
imposibilidad de recibir visitas el
centro de memoria afro díaz política
mutua anto ubicado en el pacífico
colombiano ha trasladado muchas de sus
actividades al mundo virtual
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos en
kenia porque mientras durante la última
década la población de elefantes se ha
reducido a la mitad en áfrica este país
del sur oriente del continente ha
logrado duplicar el número de
paquidermos desde 1989 la nación se ha
convertido en ejemplo de lucha contra la
extinción y ya cuenta con más de 35 mil
individuos
son las 6 30 de la mañana comienza la
ronda de patrullaje en la reserva de
luisa va las rondas de patrullaje se
realizan a diario como resultado de esta
vigilancia ningún animal ha sido
asesinado por los cazadores furtivos
desde 2017 en luisa ba pero los
guardabosques deben permanecer
vigilantes no esperamos necesariamente
encontrarnos con cazadores furtivos u
otras personas pero si tropezamos con la
gente equivocada allí estaremos para
ocuparnos de ellos [__] en los últimos
30 años se han adoptado iniciativas
similares en toda kenia como resultado
la población de elefantes se ha
duplicado y asciende a casi 35.000 los
equipos y las aplicaciones del gps que
utilizan los guardabosques son
proporcionados por la ong space for the
giants espacio para gigantes en español
actualmente el mayor temor de las
organizaciones de protección ya no son
los cazadores furtivos sino los
conflictos entre humanos y animales en
toda kenia es necesario proteger los
cultivos y explicarle a la población que
aunque los elefantes pueden causar daños
en las cosechas su presencia puede traer
ganancia
la reserva de luisao desarrolló un
programa para ayudar a la población
local en este hotel los huéspedes pueden
dormir en una verdadera cámara bajo las
estrellas el concepto fue desarrollado
por el parque pero el establecimiento le
pertenece a la comunidad es una forma
alternativa de conseguir con que
sobrevivir aquí tenemos una vida nómada
pero con el tiempo tratamos de encontrar
nuevas alternativas esto es lo que
hacemos con la conservación construimos
este lugar para atraer a los turistas la
escuela del pueblo fue construida por la
reserva al igual que el dispensario este
grupo de mujeres aprenden un oficio
gracias a los entrenamientos organizados
por lo isabá parte del dinero recaudado
por la reserva es sistemáticamente
devuelto a los habitantes una forma de
mostrarles la importancia de proteger a
los animales dijo vidic no tan bastante
antes no entendíamos por qué era
importante proteger a los animales
rivero ahora gracias a estas formaciones
hemos aprendido mucho sobre la
conservación sobre los animales del
salvajes sobre la coexistencia entre los
humanos y los animales todos estos
esfuerzos están empezando a dar sus
frutos este año el país tuvo un
excepcional de nacimientos y cada vez
menos elefantes mueren por la caza
furtiva hasta ahora 7 para guillermo han
sido asesinados en 2020 en comparación
con 34 en 2019 y 80 en 2018 cambiamos de
información porque aunque la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 no deja hasta ahora cifras de
contagios y fallecimientos tan altas
como en los otros continentes en áfrica
si afecta directamente a los niños de
los diferentes países desde ciudad del
cabo nuestro corresponsal en sudáfrica
salir fallado nos contó los detalles de
esta información
alrededor de 2 millones de niños mueren
antes de nacer en el mundo anualmente
según un informe en conjunto de la o ms
unicef el banco mundial y naciones
unidas el informe dice también que el
84% de estas muertes se producen en
países de bajos recursos y muchos de
ellos están aquí en el áfrica
sub-sahariana algunos de estos países en
el continente son línea visa o república
centroafricana y sudán del sur que
registran el mayor número de casos 62
países en el mundo sin embargo no
pudieron dar cifras porque no tienen
capacidad de hacer seguimiento esta
problemática de manera que ésta sigue
siendo una crisis es bastante
invisibilizar lado ms advierte también
que las consecuencias de la pandemia en
el sistema de salud de algunos de estos
países podría significar en un aumento
de muertes hasta entre un 11 y un 20 por
ciento según lo que dice el informe la
oms se dice también que es muy
importante fortalecer las capacidades de
auxiliar de enfermería y de parteras
tradicionales en países como nigeria
iluso de parteras tradicionales podría
reducir el alto número de muertes que se
producen durante el alumbramiento que se
con el informe representa el 40 por
ciento de las cifras de mortandad
también en marruecos y otros países del
norte
continente millones de niños han dejado
de asistir al colegio a causa de la
pandemia desde marrakech nos amplia
nuestra corresponsal el sofía catalán
la pandemia de kobe 19 ha acentuado las
desigualdades entre ellas el acceso a la
educación así se ha constatado en la
cumbre mundial de la unesco sobre
educación aquí en marruecos se mantienen
los cursos escolares pero de forma
semipresencial cada centro educativo
gestiona turnos alternados para reducir
el número de alumnos en las aulas si se
detecta algún caso de kobe 19 o se
confina la ciudad como es el caso de
casablanca se cierran los centros y se
estudia a distancia el mayor problema
reside en que gran parte del alumnado no
tiene dispositivos tecnológicos para
estudiar a distancia también que muchas
madres y padres no pueden hacerse cargo
de las horas lectivas de sus hijos y por
otra parte el 68% de estudiantes del
país según últimos datos oficiales
consideran que el plan de estudios a
distancia lo cubre todo el plan
educativo anual es todo desigualdades
que el propio ministro de educación sea
ideam se ha reconocido en la cumbre ante
la unesco y asegura que su departamento
estaría estudiando esto mientras tanto
sigue creciendo el debate sobre la gran
reforma del sistema educativo iniciada
en el año 2019 que contempla entre otras
cosas la educación obligatoria desde los
4 hasta los 15 años
se realizó la segunda ronda de
elecciones legislativas en egipto que
inició el pasado 7 de noviembre según
los sondeos los partidarios del actual
mandatario del fatal sisi llevarían
cierta delantera aunque los resultados
definitivos sólo se conocerán hasta
principios de diciembre
163 millones de electores están llamados
a elegir a los 568 parlamentarios de los
596 que integran la cámara baja el resto
de los diputados serán designados por el
cis y cuyo gobierno ha silenciado en los
últimos años cualquier intento de
oposición política sería la primera
ronda inició el pasado 24 de octubre y
se extendió durante varias semanas
colombia es el tercer país con mayor
porcentaje de población afro del
continente americano y el primero de
habla hispana la región pacífico del
país concentra gran parte de los 10
millones aproximados de
afrodescendientes que viven en esta
nación especialmente en el departamento
del chocó allí se encuentra el centro de
memoria afrojazz polica mont ventoux que
ha tenido que reinventarse en el marco
de la pandemia en la ciudad de quibdó
capital del departamento del choco
ubicado en el norte del pacífico
colombiano se encuentra el centro de
memoria afro colombiana mont ventoux un
espacio dedicado a rescatar la memoria
de los africanos y sus descendientes en
el país la región y más allá de la
diáspora monto manto centro de memoria
afro diaspórica decidió llevar la
información a nuestro público a través
de diferentes formatos uno de estos
formatos son los textos escritos
producto de nuestras propias
investigaciones en la actualidad hemos
publicado 23 libros y estamos a puertas
de publicar el libro número 24 titulado
visión de la muerte entre la gente negra
nuestras más recientes publicaciones son
esclavización y sexualización
la colonialidad de la sexualidad de la
gente negra la trata negrera y la
explicación una perspectiva histórico
psicológica y negrón en mi caballo
historia del racismo en colombia todos
nuestros textos procuran dar la
información desde la traída de los
africanos al nuevo mundo y todo lo que
ha tocado sobrevivir acaba la fundación
social afrocolombiana mont ventoux fue
creada en 2009 por el historiador sergio
antonio mosquera hoy este edificio de
cuatro plantas evoca la estructura de un
barco negrero que no esclaviza sino que
libera y ofrece una experiencia
pedagógica que sin tratarse de un museo
rememora la resistencia de los millones
de africanos que fueron secuestrados
durante la colonia y llevados a colombia
como prisioneros áfrica cuna de la
humanidad lugar de donde a partir del
siglo 16 fueron arrancados millones de
seres humanos con desciendo las américas
para el desarrollo de las minas las
haciendas y las plantaciones y así pudo
darse el crecimiento de la economía
mundial
hoy somos más de 200 millones de
habitantes afrodescendientes que
poblamos en las américas y estamos en el
imperativo histórico de reencontrarnos
de buscar nuestras raíces para poder
tener esos lazos culturales que son
importantes para sobrevivir en américa
de esta costa la costa occidental
africana fueron arrancados estos seres
de los diferentes grupos étnicos de los
diferentes imperios de los diferentes
reinos que habían prosperado en esta
parte del continente áfrica mía áfrica
de orgullo somos afrodescendientes
personas con su propio idioma su propia
historia y su propia sabiduría que hoy
está impregnada en la conciencia
colectiva del país aunque no cuente con
la suficiente visibilidad mi
reconocimiento y en la actualidad
contamos con diferentes salas y
recientemente hemos inaugurado la sala
denominada mosley que es en palenquito
donde nuestros niños desde muy temprana
edad
a leer el mundo enclave afro diaspórica
sin embargo la pandemia del cobi 19
limitó casi totalmente las visitas a
este centro de memoria durante esta
pandemia nos hemos visto obligados a
reinventarnos para llevarle satisfacción
a quienes se sientan de nuestra
información y pueden encontrarnos a
través de las redes sociales youtube
instagram y facebook no se encuentran
como monto mantuvo lo cual se convirtió
en una oportunidad para expandir sus
fronteras realizando conferencias
gratuitas desde las redes sociales
además de talleres asesorías y
conferencias virtuales que se pueden ver
desde cualquier país del mundo y
finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde costa de marfil donde la
reconocida cantante mula presentó
recientemente su nuevo videoclip que ya
cuenta con millones de reproducciones
con esta canción artista marfil ella
quiere enviar un mensaje de
empoderamiento para las jóvenes
africanas de diferentes naciones
el objetivo es que sepan que ninguna
mujer debe ser maltratadas ni
menospreciada en el marco de una
relación sentimental desde abiyán gula
nos invitó a la audiencia de áfrica a 7
días cierran 24
y su nuevo videoclip
saludos familia mi nombre es mula soy
una artista y cantante de costa de
marfil y acabo de lanzar mi nueva
canción que se llama paraíso los invito
a escucharla paraíso es una canción con
la que yo quiero expresar mi manera de
ver a la mujer africana y sobre todo a
la mujer joven africana de hoy
generación de la que hago parte lo que
quiero es que la mujer tome la palabra
que nos valoremos a nosotras mismas que
confiemos en nosotras mismas y nos
digamos que somos bellas que somos
fuertes y que podemos hacer todo lo que
queramos mientras lo decidamos y ese es
mi mensaje un beso para france24 en
español y para toda américa latina
a mí mismo
[Música]
pues con esta buena música finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días y los
invitamos a continuar con más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom y
información en cuatro idiomas que esté
con nosotros tenemos más para ustedes
[Música]
y la pérdida de eso podía ser menos
la migración del amor en las simples
tiras como ciudad y la cv televisa
este y leamos bueno